green bay packers return to santa clara
on sunday they played sunday night week
12. they'll play sunday night conference
championship weekend it's pft live nbc
sports radio nbcsn hello to our good
friends in the uk and ireland enjoying
the program on sky sports we've got a
three-man weave today big cat in new
york city chris sims in stamford
gentlemen good morning are you ready for
some football on sunday
oh yeah championship sunday there's
nothing like championship sunday because
you know cashing that ticket to the
super bowl means something you get to
see the celebration if you're a fan then
you get two weeks to get excited for
your team in the super bowl there's
nothing like championship sunday yeah i
love i mean i i don't know i i argue
it's almost every bit as exciting as
super bowl sunday to me first off you
get the double header right uh so you
enjoy that i mean two games in a row
it's the last time all year we're gonna
do that but i am pumped i kind of treat
it like super bowl sunday i'm gonna be
sitting in the living room you know
watching tv feeling good maybe a drink
lots of food and munchies to eat and i'm
gonna enjoy myself
yeah and both games this year are
rematches of games that were played in
the regular season and let's start with
the game that was the sunday night
football feature week 12 green bay
packers at the san francisco 49ers
remember it was the first game for the
49ers on that three-game gauntlet where
they were facing
teams with winning percentages above 80
percent first time in the super bowl era
that that had happened that a team had
faced three opponents that are that good
and they had a hard time with the ravens
they had a hard time with the saints
they had an easy time with the green bay
packers but guys i've gone back and
watched that game chris i know you
studied the film and big cat if you
haven't gone back and watched it the nfl
game pass feature it's awesome you can
go back and watch that game in like 40
minutes it's obvious that that game
turned on a few moments and you take
those moments away or you flip them the
other way big cat and this could be a
very different outcome i mean if i'm the
49ers i'm very nervous about this
because it's starting off zero and zero
not 20 to nothing not 23 to nothing not
37 to 8 you don't mash it together like
they do on jeopardy when they play two
uh matches back to back 37.8 is gone and
i think that puts a ton of pressure on
the 49ers big cat do you agree yeah i i
agree about the pressure part because
anytime you have such a lopsided game in
the regular season it always feels like
the team that lost is going to feel you
know like hey we got we got really we
got to hand it to us when we went out
there last time we have something to
prove and the other team that won the
49ers here are saying we can handle
these guys pretty easily if we just go
out and do our job and do what we did
last time that rarely happens in sports
so yes i agree on the pressure
standpoint there
i just i've been
saying for the last i don't know three
months that i do not believe in the
green bay packers they're gonna prove me
wrong every single week i'm gonna be the
guy sitting in miami saying that they're
a fraudulent team even though they went
13-3 and got to the super bowl that's
just going to happen to me so i'm
sitting here i'm trying to find a way
that they're going to win this game and
i just keep saying that the 49ers have
too much and i hope that's the case and
i know i'll be be wrong well i you know
hey
i hear you first off i mean first off
this is big cat what you said this is
something me and mike talked about a lot
this week the psychosis you're right is
on the advantage of the green bay
packers because the 49ers are waking up
feeling good oh we beat this team the
packers are waking up with the fear of
god like oh i hope we don't get blown
out off the field once again so you're
right about that and you're right about
the packers like i hear you questioning
them there's things to question i think
it's one of the more underwhelming
number two seeds we've ever seen now
yeah they might shove it up all our
butts here and win the super bowl who
knows i still feel like the 49ers were
clearly the better football team and
pose problems for green bay you know i
feel like the room for error is very
little for green bay they almost have to
play the perfect game and i want to say
like maybe they can win but the other
wrinkle in that is what mike and i
witnessed last week you know will jimmy
g crap down his leg can kyle shanahan
trust him in some of the big moments or
at all throughout the game to
consistently deliver because
i do think a jimmy garoppolo two
interceptions or something like that
even if green bay isn't playing the
perfect game there that brings them back
and i go oh okay well then that can
change things and then the pressure will
go back onto the san francisco 49ers so
let me ask you this chris yeah because
last week i i it was interesting to
watch that game the 49ers and vikings
because it felt like jimmy g has that
interception early and kyle shanahan
said we're not going to let you lose
this game for us we're going to run the
ball over and over and over until they
stop it which they weren't able to do
you think there's going to be a similar
game plan where it's not
jimmy g is better than a game manager
yeah kyle shanahan might have a game
plan ready to go if things go south
where it's jimmy g you're not going to
lose this for us we're going to let our
defense and our running attack
get and win this game and let you just
kind of handle i mean jimmy
jimmy doesn't throw down field that much
like right he's not stretching the field
he just has to do enough to keep them in
the game and not kill them to win this
game yeah no i think that's very real
big cat i mean if you're kyle i think
you know you're saying it if you're kyle
shanahan i'm kyle shanahan i'm going in
the nfc championship game this weekend
yeah feeling good about my team but a
little nervous about my quarterback and
some of the shaky decisions and throws
he made not only were some of the
decisions bad you know some of the
throws were bad and i do think that kyle
will have some game plan plays whether
it's screens or just early completions
you know or easy completions early on to
get him in that flow but to that point
this is another thing i believe in like
green bay you just said it big cat they
don't throw the ball down the field they
don't stretch the field if i'm green bay
load the middle i mean i'm loading
everybody in there shanahan and
garoppolo love to throw the ball over
the middle you got good corners in green
bay let them play man-to-man on the
outside put eight or nine or ten guys in
the middle of that field take away the
run game take away all those little
slants we see shanahan dice up defenses
with on a weekly basis so there's a lot
of good things there
and i can understand why big cat would
prefer to talk about jimmy garoppolo
instead of the quarterback who has
haunted him
roger and aaron rodgers look everything
we saw from jimmy garoppolo on saturday
that may have caused kyle shanahan to do
the break glass in event of emergency
run the ball run the ball run the ball
game plan and it worked
we saw i think something special from
aaron rodgers on sunday it reminded me
of who he was at his very best it
reminded us all that he still is at his
very best he's mobile he's accurate he's
effortless and if that same aaron
rodgers shows up on sunday in santa
clara not too far from where he grew up
facing the team he grew up rooting for
the team that passed over him back in
2005 and he's keenly aware that he is
getting closer and closer to the end of
the road look i think his mindset and as
it was manifested against the seahawks
that is a dangerous thing for the 49ers
to deal with because guys i'm telling
you go back and watch the game it was a
stupid penalty on devante adams that
kind of sparked that yes drive that
ended with the turnover and the easy
touchdown for the 49ers it was dumb
decisions like shotgun formation running
on fourth and one it was one thing here
one thing there next thing you know it's
23 to nothing at halftime i don't think
that's going to happen this time to the
packers and the closer they keep it big
cat the longer it goes where the packers
are in it i think that's when jimmy
garoppolo and the rest of the 49ers get
a little more nervous and that's when
the packers start thinking hey
dummies you let us hang around now we're
going to take it all right two things
here chris sims your goat aaron rodgers
if he wins this game he will still have
a worst winning percentage in the
playoffs than joe flacco and they both
have one one super bowl to uh their
names so just want to put this in
perspective for the people watching at
home
two
mike you just brought up devonte adams
what the 49ers do is they always shut
down the best guy on the other side of
the ball so i you know the first time
the the the packers are down all game
davonte adams has 43 yards on seven
receptions he did not have a big game
against the 49ers the first time around
yet last week when aaron rodgers looked
like aaron rodgers again like you just
said what happened devonte adams has an
enormous game he busts out he's running
all over the field i just don't think
that's going to be there for aaron
rodgers the same way it was there last
week the 49ers do a great job of taking
away your best option and devonte adams
is not going to be able to run free and
wild like he was against the seahawks on
lambeau
at lambeau on sunday
all right so first off don't come on
this show and start taking shots at
aaron rodgers okay i will come over
there to new york that's my job all
right good that's my job how dare you
and joe flacco yeah he's got a better
record he's he was on more he was on
better playoff teams than aaron rodgers
oh my gosh yes the packers were 15 and
one and blew it oh my god
you boil it down to one guy all the time
and that's you know i just don't agree
with that i don't agree with that but
either way i will say this okay
you know you both are kind of hitting on
it i think they got to put the game in
rogers hands i'm not going to sit here
and go oh i think aaron jones is going
to get it done against this 49ers front
at home with loud crowd noise getting
off the ball i think they're going to be
very aware of aaron jones to me the game
will go back to uh the great number 12.
and i think they just got to ride him
whether that's you know mike we talked
about this it's got to be a lot of quick
passes and like quick screens out on the
edge to the to devonta adams or the
receivers so the pass rush can't get
home because they had issues with the
pass rush the first time i think that's
the way you settle them down the other
thing is where i just say okay if green
bay wants to make plays in the pass game
keep six seven eight guys into protect
and work it down field the 49ers play
the same defensive scheme the seattle
seahawks do work devonte adams
man-to-man on sherman or mostly you know
let him be protected he doesn't have to
think and then he could just throw one
of his you know lasers over there
20-yard out route whatever it may be i
think ultimately it will come down to
rogers having to win this game whether
he can do it i don't know that you know
this is a really really good football
team the 49ers are the better team here
but they have a shaky quarterback that
pressures on them and green bay seems to
find ways to win ugly football games and
the one thing that came through loud and
clear to me watching the game back from
week 12 and comparing it to the
experience the 49ers defensive line had
on saturday against kirk cousins who has
no mobility whatsoever and just
collapses when the walls close in if
they can get aaron rodgers out of the
pocket not when they have to make it
part of the design don't wait until the
walls start to cave in keep him on the
move the more he's on the move the
harder it's going to be for the 49ers
front four to get to him and there were
some moments in that first game where
nick bosa gets kind of faked out of his
underwear by aaron rodgers aaron rodgers
even at 36 he can outrun those guys and
they need to keep him on the move as
often as they can if he's in the pocket
that ball's got to be out within two
seconds you cannot put him back there
and make him a sitting duck like kirk
cousins was that's what's going to kill
drives that's what's going to cause
turnovers like the one that that started
the avalanche in week 12. they need to
learn from what happened last time and i
think it's an easy fix chris and it's
one of those things that's just laying
out there in plain sight keep aaron
rodgers on the move and if you do that
you're going to have frustrated and
tired front four for the 49ers and i
think come the third or fourth quarter
uh the the packers reap the benefit of
it yeah well i i i
listen i don't disagree with what you're
saying there yeah move them quick passes
okay block it up bam let's throw deep
outside the numbers whatever it may be
to devonte adams
but yes the goal was going to be
get away from what happened in week 12
which was an avalanche on rogers most
times he dropped back to pass and the
packers as we've talked about a lot
they'll be better suited the second time
around there is something to that when
you've seen you know these freaks of
nature at least once in in person and
bosa and d ford and the tr the two tree
trunks from oregon in the middle you
know hey yeah it does help that you've
seen there been there done that and they
won't be as maybe shocked by the size
and and uh you know explosiveness that
all these guys have
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports